LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O.
I'm Louis Gray here
from the Moscone
Center in San Francisco.
I've got a great guest here
today, Bradley Horowitz, Vice
President of Product
on Google+.
Welcome, Bradley.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Thank you.
LOUIS GRAY: This is an
incredible event here at
Google I/O. This is
my fourth time
attending, second as a Googler.
I came twice as press,
if you recall.
How many times have
you been here?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I guess
three that I can recall.
I'm not sure I made
it the first year.
LOUIS GRAY: We've got like 6,000
developers, and I swear
all of them are right
next to us.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah,
it's amazing.
It's really exciting.
LOUIS GRAY: It's just been,
I think, a really great
opportunity to connect to the
developers who interact with
our products, take a look at
each one of them, be it
Chrome, Android, Google+
obviously, YouTube, and really
get to talk directly
to the people who
are making this happen.
That's part of what we're
trying to do with Google
Developers Live is get that
immediate, direct access.
Now, there's a lot
of people who
watched the keynote yesterday.
It was an incredible keynote,
three and a half hours, and
just action packed.
Let's talk a little bit about
what Google+ announced for
those people who could have
missed it or haven't gotten
deep to understand what
was introduced.
Can you take us through that?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah,
absolutely.
So the keynote was epic.
I mean, it was a huge day for
me personally, for our team,
and I think for Google, too.
And we had a section in there
where Vic, who is our rockstar
leader, got up and announced
really three major themes for
Google+ that all landed
on the same day.
The first is one that is
basically a complete redesign
of the stream, and really a
rethinking of the stream.
It's not simply a
visual design.
It works and behaves in
new and exciting ways.
That in itself was a
major undertaking.
It touched every part of our
product, and it's almost a
relaunch of Google+ itself.
LOUIS GRAY: It's dramatically
different.
When we looked at it, they
talked about really adding
depth to Google+.
The discussion was many
different sites are often very
flat, and with the Google+
redesign, you can take me
through some of--
either the thinking about how do
you do the redesign in the
first place, and then what were
some key elements you
wanted to make sure
you delivered on
when this went live.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah, we could
spend an hour just on
that first element of
what we launched.
LOUIS GRAY: Then you'll have to
come back when I get back
to Mountain View.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: That's
fine, too.
So as I said, it's more than
just a visual design.
One of the things that
inspired this was our
development process.
We are developing for
multiple platforms.
We have been getting huge
accolades and praise from the
press and our users around our
mobile and tablet designs, and
we also felt some frustration
that the desktop experience
wasn't up to par, wasn't
consistent, wasn't inspiring
the same kinds of adjectives
that the mobile and tablet
experience were.
So part of what inspired this
was the disparity between
those experiences, and what we
saw as an opportunity to
reconcile them.
We started asking ourselves,
why are they different?
Why wouldn't they converge in
terms of how they behave?
And so I think that is part of
the art of developing across
platforms is understanding and
having principles around where
things converge and where they
diverge, because it's not that
you want the experience
on a mobile device
to simply be smaller.
That's not the right answer
and we know that.
So we put a lot of thought
into that.
We came up with something
I think is beautiful.
It is a multi-column card
interface that really brings
the content to the fore.
And I think that's one of the
design principles was to allow
the content to shine, to be
the hero in the product.
Things like menus recede
gracefully to the side when
you don't need them and appear
when you do, and that's one of
the other principles, is
emergent functionality.
Stuff is there but it's
not cluttered.
It's not attracting your
attention or detracting from
the content itself.
LOUIS GRAY: We talked a few
times already at GDL talking
about that unification
of design.
I think that was a big thing
that came out of the keynote,
that you're essentially having
the same exact experience on a
smartphone, a tablet, or your
desktop, and you saw that with
the Google Play Store redesign,
you've seen that
with Chrome, you've seen
that with some of the
Notification updates.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Google Now.
LOUIS GRAY: --and Google
Now especially.
And now Google+, I think, has
been one of those big pieces.
So that was one of the
three things that
you announced yesterday.
Let's talk about
the other two.
One of them was obviously
the Hangouts app.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Well,
I didn't even
get through the first.
I mean, we didn't talk about
auto hashtagging.
We didn't talk about
the dimensionality.
I mean, just to briefly touch
on that and then we'll talk
about Hangouts.
Most streams are sort of like a
newspaper that moves through
a View Port in one dimension.
It's really very flat.
What we've done also
is introduced
depth to the stream.
Part of that is literally
cinematographic kind of
animation so that you can flip
a card around and there's
information on the
back of the card.
But more metaphorically, we've
introduced depth in the sense
that we are really leaning
on hashtags.
Now, hashtags are great.
Chris Messina, one of our own
Googlers, is credited with
having invented the concept.
But in most social media, very
small fractions of the content
actually benefit from hashtags
and there's well known
problems with hashtags.
There's race conditions, what is
the canonical hashtag for a
given topic for a news event?
We think we've solved
those in a way
that is a Google approach.
So what we do is we
automatically hashtag content.
We look at the words,
of course, the
semantics behind it.
We look at the images so we can
actually do image analysis
and tag images based on the
content of the images.
LOUIS GRAY: I saw in some of
those demos, there was an
example of an Eiffel Tower photo
where the person had no
hashtags inserted at all, didn't
even mention Eiffel
Tower in the post, and yet
Google knew, with the type of
analysis and algorithms that
we have, that this was the
Eiffel Tower and they hashtagged
it automatically,
and that was nifty.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
It's incredible.
And it works for landmarks,
it can work for
categories of images.
It's something I hope
everyone can try.
The cool thing about this
is that we have
the Knowledge Graph.
We have knowledge of
clustering and
can apply these hashtags.
So hashtags become these
doorways to explore content.
If there's a particular thing
I'm interested in, I click on
the hashtag and on the back of
the card are more that I can
swipe through, and it's a way
to really dive through the
content in a new dimension.
LOUIS GRAY: One of the things
that's really come up about
Google+ in the last few years
since you debuted is the
following of interests, going
beyond people and the
relationships you have
in real life to
having shared interests.
And we've seen that with
Communities, which were
introduced earlier this year,
I believe, as well as this
kind of hashtag approach, where
you can find out more
people talking about the
same things that
you're interested in.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Exactly.
LOUIS GRAY: How have you
looked at that from a
philosophical standpoint
where you have that--
not a dichotomy, but a different
way of looking at
how content flows through
between people and interests?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Yeah, I really
appreciate that use case.
That's one of the advantages
of being here is you really
learn how people are
using the product.
And as you point out, interests
are one of the main
success stories of Google+,
people discovering people with
common interests
or affinities.
The truth is, I think we haven't
done enough to really
make that use case shine,
and I think this hashtag
opportunity gives people a new
vector to connect to other
people, to connect to content
that matters to them.
And so this is really a
recognition of that use case
and doubling down in a way
that I think will really
promote that use case.
People have sort of been doing
it around the product, and now
the product is leaning
into that trend and
facilitating this.
So I really think this is
a major innovation.
It's sort of a Google
kind of problem.
The ability to do this automatic
hashtagging requires
lots of artificial intelligence,
machine
learning, across languages.
It's very impressive
technology.
The other thing I want to
mention is that we always put
the content owner first.
So if you hashtag your own
content, that gets preferred
and those hashtags
will appear.
We distinguish between user
entered hashtags and machine
algorithm generated hashtags.
If you don't like the hashtags
we put there, you can x them
out on a per hashtag basis or
you can opt out entirely and
say, don't hashtag my content.
LOUIS GRAY: And you're talking
about the stream.
It's really interesting.
There's so much content flowing
through Google+ right
now, especially depending how
many people you're following,
as you follow interests,
I've seen some
Communities just explode.
And the interesting thing is
that not all posts are created
equal, and I think that gets
called out a little bit in the
new redesign, and you have
certain posts that can span
multiple columns.
Tell us a little
bit about that.
Is that just something, like if
I put a horizontal photo,
is it just going to expand
out like that, or
how does that work?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: No, it's
actually intelligent about
how, as you said, all content's
not created equal.
And pending the nature of the
content, as you mentioned,
media content renders really
well and deserves this kind of
full screen treatment.
Part of it is the affinity you
have to the content itself,
both the poster and the topic.
And so we'll bring the right
content to you in the right
format, and this ability to have
these superposts which
get more screen real estate and
attention is one of the
big benefits of the
new redesign that
we're excited about.
LOUIS GRAY: And superposting
works actually really well,
going back to photos.
Obviously, the photo
community has been
incredible on Google+.
It's really been something where
I've seen a lot of focus
from the team, not only the
Photos Team explicitly, but
from Vic all the way down,
really diving in,
understanding how photos and a
visual design experience can
really differentiate Google+.
And I know we're not going in
order, but I want to talk a
little bit about photos.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: That's fine.
LOUIS GRAY: You've introduced,
you call it Auto Awesome and
some auto enhancements.
And it seems like you're not
just accepting of photos,
you're embracing it and making
it a big part of that
experience.
What is it about photography
that has exploded on Google+?
Why is it happening here?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I think it's
back to that respect for the
content owner.
What we're trying to do is get
out of the way and allow this
stuff to be presented in the
most beautiful form, and then
to connect up audiences with
content producers.
So what's not to love in that
equation where we have no
agenda other than to help you
find and reach your audience
and put your content
in the best light?
So that has been noticed and
acclaimed, and we've gotten
into this very nice rhythm
with photographers where
they've come onto the service,
filled it up with great
content, and we're listening
to make the
service better and better.
And as you pointed out,
the second big theme--
we're not going in Vic's order--
but the second big
theme of yesterday's
announcements was a slew of
new features and capabilities
on photos.
And this was not necessarily
for the very top of the
pyramid, the Thomas Hawks
and Trey Ratcliffs.
LOUIS GRAY: You mean for the
professional photographers.
This is for everybody.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: This is for
everybody, and we're sort of
raising the bar.
And the best way to think about
this-- the way that I
liked that Vic framed
in the keynote--
Google has tremendous data
centers, bandwidth, computing
power, and we introduced a long
time ago this feature
that allows you to instantly
upload your content, your
photos, into our cloud,
and that's fantastic.
LOUIS GRAY: With any device
that's connected, right?
So if I take a picture with my
Android device or my iPhone or
iPad if they're connected,
or even Glass, that'll be
instantly uploaded and available
for me, auto backup,
to get to and retrieve.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: And it's
really self evident.
I think once we did this,
it was widely
copied in the industry.
And of course, my content
should not be
locked on an SD card.
If you ask people, how many of
you have pictures on your
phone that you never got
around to sharing or
liberating or doing anything
with, everyone
raised their hands.
And in this day and age, we're
all cycling through phones.
You basically put it in a drawer
or hand it down to
generations, and so having
that content trapped on a
device, especially one that is
internet connected, is absurd.
So that's widely
understood now.
We introduced that feature
and people love it
and appreciate it.
But that is the tip
of the iceberg.
It's table stakes.
It's the most modest thing we
could do with what Google
could offer to users, and what
we launched yesterday were
three more enhancements that I
really think speak to what a
cloud-based approach to
photography can do.
The first one is auto curation
and the ability to highlight
your photos.
So all of us are in a state now
where we go on vacation,
we come home, and you've got
a folder full of photos--
hundreds, maybe even 1,000.
I went to Morocco recently,
took about 1,000 pictures.
The problem is you don't get a
second vacation to go through
your first vacation's
photos, right?
LOUIS GRAY: And even for those
of us who don't have the
luxury to go to Morocco, I've
got three kids four and under,
and so they're beautiful
and it's fun to
take photos of them.
But I'm spending most of the
time trying to get them to go
to bed be obedient rather than
trying to add shadows here and
do texturing and find
the right ones.
And so it really made sense
to me when Vic gave his
presentation about not only
looking at 600 photos and
taking it down to the top 40,
but also the fun ones where
you say, none of the kids are
looking at the right place at
the right time and you
kind of animate that.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So we
all feel this problem.
I mean again, everyone raises
their hands and understands
the auto backup functionality.
But if you say, how many of
you have taken more photos
than you know what to
do with, everyone
will raise their hand.
And so some of what we're
doing to help with this
curation problem is sort
of self evident.
We'll get rid of the
blurry ones.
overexposed ones or
underexposed ones when they're
beyond repair, and we'll get
to repair in a minute.
But some of what we're doing
is really very clever.
Were able to find people in the
photos, understand your
affinity to those people,
understand, are they smiling
in the photos.
And what we're doing is we're
taking what is an intractable
problem-- going through
1,000 photos--
and coming up with a starting
set where here's the 25 we
think would be a great
representation of your vacation.
Did we get it right?
And you can go in and actually
say, no, that one isn't what I
want to share.
I prefer this one.
And of course, every time you
do that, it's helping make
algorithms smarter.
You're actually volunteering
a bit of information to the
global commons that will help
tune our algorithms.
And ultimately, they'll
be individually tuned.
If you prefer somber shots where
people aren't smiling,
we should offer you that.
LOUIS GRAY: [INAUDIBLE]
this is my serious face.
But you talk about helping the
algorithm get better, and I
want to touch on that a
little bit before we
jump back into Hangouts.
When you look at Google+, it
really is kind of two pieces.
You've not only got the
destination site, which is
incredible and has a beautiful
new look, and a lot of people
are talking and engaging and
sharing their interests, but
it's making other Google
products better.
And you could see that yesterday
especially when you
talk about new maps, and
Google Play with
recommendations from your
friends, and all
these little pieces.
How do you balance those two--
I don't want to say competing
interests,
but separate interests?
You've got a team of people
who's got a lot of work to do,
a bug list a mile long, features
they want to get out.
How do you go ahead and say,
we've really got to make a
better experience for
Google with Google+?
I want to talk about that
philosophy and how you're
going to do that.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Well as you
know, it's been part of our
stated strategy for a long time
is to be not just a site,
not just a new product, but a
horizontal, social spine, a
layer of infrastructure that
makes all products better.
And ultimately, as you'll talk
to Seth, I think, after me, it
not just makes all Google
products better.
It makes all products on the web
better, and it's something
we want to offer to publishers
and developers as well.
How do we balance those?
As you point out, I don't think
they're competing, but
there are finite resources and
only so many hours in the day,
and so we have to sort of
thread that needle.
I think part of Vic's leadership
is to understand
that this is a journey, that
it's not something we ever
anticipated we'd be done
with in 20 months.
And while we're delighted with
the usage and the uptake and
the progress that we're making,
we've got a roadmap
that will carry us for a very
long time and some very
exciting things ahead of us.
As you point out, I can't think
of a product or team at
Google that isn't already
working with us and won't
revolutionize the functionality
of their own
product through better and
deeper integration.
LOUIS GRAY: I think that's
something that you and I know
inherently because we've been
close to Google+ for a long
time, and I think some of the
challenge of bringing our
knowledge and our comfort level
with everything that
we're doing with Google+ to the
outside world, and I think
we have an opportunity now to
do that where people will
really get what we're
thinking.
People often talk
about success.
How do you measure that success,
whether it's at a 12
month standpoint, a 24 month?
And you say, it is
a long vision.
You how do you know you're
on the right
track and doing well?
What kind of feedback
do you get?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: That's
a great question.
Well the first, something we're
very attuned to as a
team, are the metrics.
LOUIS GRAY: What kind
of metrics?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Well, we
measure everything, so time
spent and engagement.
These are health indexes for
our own products, and we're
very attuned to them, and we
strive to understand them,
measure them, and improve
all of those metrics.
So that's one way.
In terms of what we share
publicly, obviously our
Dashboards are useful
internal tools.
Our public numbers right now are
about 190 million monthly
actives on Google+ itself,
the mobile client
or the Google+ site.
We're happy with that.
It took other social companies
five years, seven years to get
to 200 million.
200 million is right
in sight for us.
And that's incredible usage,
incredibly engaged users.
As you point out, there's
content that's exploding on
the system and we're just
getting started.
So all of that is very
validating and a great way to
measure the success
of the product.
I do think that we are
never satisfied.
And so while all of those
trends are in the right
direction, there's
so much to do.
People in the session I
just left were saying,
where's your analytics?
You need analytics for us to
take the platform seriously.
They're right.
Where's your API?
We want you to more fully open
the API and then continue down
the platform.
LOUIS GRAY: Actually
earlier today, we
had the Google+ Sandbox.
We did a walk through
and highlighted a
number of those partners.
We're definitely going to have
a chance to talk with Seth.
I think the interesting part
to me, having seen it from
both sides--
both first outside of Google
and now inside--
is externally, you have
people's expectations.
They really want to
get to the code.
They've been asking for certain
types of APIs and
actually, a different type of
write APIs and this and that.
And that's something that Vic's
addressed a few times
and trying to do this
in the right way.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Exactly.
LOUIS GRAY: And patience
is hard.
It's hard to be taught and to
make sure you do it in an
excellent way that's good for
your users and developers.
And what can we tell developers
right now who want
to know that Google+ is a place
that they should invest
their time?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: That's a great
question, and I think it
does require patience to grow a
network like we're growing,
and we don't want to
inorganically sort
of pour users in.
We want it to have a healthy
sort of trajectory.
We think that growth
for its own sake--
we're not just looking
for spikes.
We're looking for sustained,
organic, viral, exponential
growth, and that happens
over time.
Now some of this, as I pointed
out, we've managed to compress
seven years into 20 months.
That's awesome.
But things have to happen in a
sequential order and as we
open up APIs--
Vic's talked a lot about this--
we want to ensure the
integrity of the system both
from a spam and abuse point,
from making sure the content
reached the right users in the
right moment in the right way.
There's a lot of science behind
that and some of that
has to be learned
in the field.
And so we've continued to
introduce new APIs, new
functionality, Google+ Sign In,
all of these things, in
disciplined, thoughtful ways
that have not impeded but
rather accreted value to our
growth trajectories and the
value of the network.
LOUIS GRAY: And I think there's
also three pieces we
touched on a number of times in
the keynote, and touched on
a little bit with
spam and abuse.
We talk about three things, and
that's speed, security,
simplicity.
And I think you touched a little
bit on security and
simplicity of getting photos up
there, simplicity of being
able to post.
What about speed?
How do you measure
if something's
happening quick enough?
What is a good load time?
How does that impact you guys?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: We care so
deeply about latency and
speed, and it's across
a number of levels.
One is just page load time being
as efficient as we can,
making sure we're doing
things right.
I know there's lots of sessions
here, but our
internal hygiene there is
rigorous and we care deeply
about that.
It's everything from how the
system's architected to how
the page is rendering in
specific browsers.
So that's one aspect of speed.
Another is for things like--
I haven't even gone through the
features of autoenhancing
your images, but these are
compute intensive features,
and so thinking about how we
take advantage of Google's
Global Compute Infrastructure
to do that in a way that is
efficient is another aspect,
making sure the algorithms are
efficient, making sure that
users' expectations are in
line with what we can deliver,
all of these things.
For instance, auto hashtagging,
one thing the
team struggled with is could
we do it in real time?
Could you post something and
have the post drop into your
stream with the hashtags
directly on it?
That was a big challenge because
what we wanted, again,
in deference to the content
owner, we didn't want you to
have to come back tomorrow to
see how your post was tagged.
We wanted that to
be real time.
LOUIS GRAY: You don't want to
go back and fix it five
minutes later or five hours
later or any of that stuff.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: It had
to be interactive.
And so speed is, throughout
our product, of foremost
concern and we think about it
deeply and in subtle ways and
in the forefront of what a lot
of our teams are working on.
LOUIS GRAY: And one of the other
forefront pieces you've
got is Hangouts.
I always used to say Hangouts
is kind of that hammer that
hits all the nails.
It's just been an exciting thing
that Google+ had that
was a significant
differentiator, and it's been
there since day one.
And Hangouts has really grown
into something else now.
We have the On Air capability,
and the new app that launched
yesterday which really unifies
a lot of our messaging.
So let's talk about that.
I definitely don't want
to miss that.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: OK.
There's so many more photo
features I would love to talk
about but in the interest of
time, I'll take your lead and
we'll talk about Hangouts.
Hangouts is an incredibly
beautiful,
simple and subtle product.
I'm really proud of the team.
It took a lot of craft and
discipline from a product
standpoint to build something
that just works.
It's not the sort of wow factor
of, enhance your photos
or automatically hashtag
something.
It is just a beautiful,
thoughtful, convenient product
experience that just works
like it should.
One of the things Vic took you
through was a matrix, and
aren't there already products
that fulfill this?
And the truth is--
LOUIS GRAY: I've been able to
send you a chat before, I've
been able to send you photos
before, but I think that
matrix essentially shows photos,
videos, and text
across different devices--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Single
user, multi-user.
LOUIS GRAY: They're talking
about three
dimensions now, Bradley.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah,
it's a cube.
There really is no product
that met all of those
requirements.
And I really think we've nailed
it and we're going to
put something in everyone's
pocket, irrespective of
device, or in front
of everyone.
Maybe it's not your pocket.
Maybe it's on your face or
maybe it's on your desk.
But we're going to put it
everywhere you need it.
And it will be the simplest
way to really connect to
another person, whether that's
text, photos, emoji, or real
time, face-to-face interaction
between groups of people.
We are going to span
that entire gamut.
And for Google, I think
distribution has never been
our problem.
If we had a great product, we
have an opportunity to get
that in people's hands, and I
don't think we've stepped up
and created the right product
until yesterday
and we now have that.
LOUIS GRAY: Solving these
problems are hard.
I think one of the behind the
scenes, I think [INAUDIBLE]
did a big run through of
the Hangouts creation.
It's a challenge to take the
many different products that
we have and make a beautiful,
seamless user experience like
Larry often talks about, and
Vic often talks about.
And so we've seen that with
Google+, we're seeing it again
with Hangouts.
And one interesting thing about
Hangouts, because it's
such a shining star of Google+,
it's gotten a lot of
attention but it's also gotten
a lot of real world use that
kind of goes unspoken.
When I was in Europe, I did a
Hangout with my kids and my
wife every single day.
We were separated by what?
6,000 miles, give or take, eight
or nine hours, and every
day I spoke face to face
with my kids and
they just expect it.
They've come to believe that
they can pick up a Nexus 7,
ask Google anything, get the
answer they want, connect with
anyone, anytime.
I mean, just even simple things
like getting a movie on
Google Play on instant, it's
incredible what they believe.
And you look at Hangouts--
even last night after we wrapped
up at seven o'clock, I
went to the hotel and my wife
sent me a message on Hangout
that says, can we do
a Hangout now?
I said sure, and got to talk to
my kids and tell them all
to go to bed and pick
up their toys.
So how has Hangouts really
changed the way that you
collaborate, either at
work or at home?
Are you still having fun just
hitting the Hangout button and
waiting for people?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: It's changed
it dramatically.
I think as you're pointing
out, we have these high
profile Hangouts On Air.
We have the President, and the
Dalai Lama and chiefs of
state, and--
LOUIS GRAY: All the way
down to my kids.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yes, right.
So that stuff gets the attention
a lot of times.
But what is more exciting to
me is people just using
Hangouts in this private,
important way to connect to
other people.
So the use case you talked
about I experience
myself all the time.
When I'm traveling, it's the
best way to connect face to
face with the family and have
an authentic, great
connection.
It's so much better
than a call.
You hand the phone to the
kids, and they don't
even want to talk.
But if you can see them, and
I'm often using the Effects
and we're having fun.
We're laughing, we're
interacting,
it's real, it's visceral.
So I'm a fan of that use case.
But you pointed out at work.
One of our leaders, Shi Chu,
who was the VP under whom
Hangouts was built, mentioned
in the previous session that
Google itself conducts more than
20,000 Hangouts a day.
So this has become an integral
piece of our own workflow.
We can't get through the day
without using Hangouts to
connect to our distributed
offices and actually
get our jobs done.
So it's not only for fun and
giggles and laughs and
connection with the family.
It's for serious work.
We actually use screen
sharing, we do our
presentations this way, we
interact as teams over
Hangouts, and it's really
spanning the gamut of
communication, everything from
the ridiculous to the sublime.
And so it's a part of my daily
life every day of my life.
LOUIS GRAY: So one of the things
we talked about, we
talked about Interests.
How do people factor into
Google+ and Google at large?
I mean, I know there's a kind
of what would be called a
rallying cry or really the
genesis of Google+.
It wasn't just that you
had a lot of people
who wanted some work.
What has sparked that, and how
is that continuing today?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Well, I love
the way Vic put it yesterday
in his keynote.
He said technology should get
out of the way so that we can
do what we're really here to
do-- live, learn, and love.
Those are the things that are
important in people's lives
and technology should not be
a bright, shiny object that
detracts from that.
On the contrary, it should
empower that and enable that,
and that's what we're trying
to do at Google writ large,
but also at Google+, is sort of
get the technology out of
the way and allow that
connection to happen.
And it informs our design, it
informs our product direction,
and it informs the thinking.
One of the things I
loved yesterday--
it was a long keynote, but the
thread of people and of
living, learning, loving, and
the connection was present
throughout every presenter's
moment up there.
LOUIS GRAY: Concluding
with Larry.
I think one of the things we've
touched on a few times
with GDL at I/O is at Google,
we actually have an
opportunity to hear from Larry
about once a week,
some people even more.
And the interesting thing about
Larry is he doesn't talk
about product, details,
and features and get
deep down in it.
He talks about the way that it
can transform humanity, and
the opportunity that's available
through technology,
and the things that Google
should be doing.
And I thought it was a real
pleasure to see that kind of
direct access to Larry by all
the developers who are here
and those who are watching on
the Live Stream as well.
And I think the type of things
you're talking about, which
are very emotive and feeling
oriented, are something that
has been a key for Google+ from
the beginning and we're
really seeing comes
from the very top.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah,
it really does.
And you said he doesn't
get into the details.
He actually does, and he has got
fantastic insights at that
level, too.
But I think you're right.
What is thrilling is to be a
part of that vision, to think
about the way that Larry thinks
about the problems, to
catch some of that yesterday
when he was saying things
like, "we should be building
products that don't yet
exist."
It is so natural for us as
humans to gravitate to the
comfortable, the known, to think
of things in reference
to other things, and we don't
even realize how much that
inhibits our creativity.
And Larry is just masterful
at breaking through those
constraints and barriers and
upleveling people's thinking
to greatness.
He's a really great model
of that, but he
also inspires others.
And so I was thrilled that he
had a chance to literally
inspire millions yesterday and
give people a taste of what
it's like to work with
him and for him.
LOUIS GRAY: It was
exceptional.
I'm glad you touched on that.
The very first person I spoke to
at GDL at I/O yesterday was
Megan Smith, VP of Google X. We
talked about Moonshots, and
it's really an incredible
opportunity to change the
world at a big level.
And so I definitely thank
you for coming on.
We're just about out of time.
And right up after this, we have
Seth Sternberg on Google+
as well talking about
Google+ Sign In.
To we're going to lead with
you and cut over to Seth.
So for those of you watching
on the stream, stay tuned.
While we're getting Seth ready,
go ahead and make sure
to take the time to go to
YouTube and subscribe to
Google Developers.
Thank you very much, Bradley.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Thank you.
It was a pleasure.
LOUIS GRAY: Appreciate it.